if I have a book that says how to Market
a book and it has 10 reviews on Amazon
do I need to consume the book no I
already know the book sucks cuz I have
evidence that the book sucks I have
visual proof that everything you're
saying is not true or that you weren't
even doing it it's just like the teacher
who says I'm giving Financial advice to
people and they're like my advice is
better than Warren Buffett it's like
yeah sure you just forgot to build an
$800 billion company no big deal right
that's it it's the lens that everyone's
going to perceive everything you say
through I want people to have the
evidence so that when they speak about
something they can be confident about it
confident because they have a high
degree of probability that it is true
because they've experienced it